Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist trial of the arms of the god. Slender chainlets stretched from his fingers up to his shoulders and fell behind, where men, by pulling them, made the two hands rise to a level with the elbows and come close together against the belly. They were moved several times in succession with little abrupt jerks. Then the instruments were still. The fire roared.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishist。神之双臂的审判。细小的链条从他的指尖一直延伸到肩膀，垂在身后。人们拉动链条，使那双手臂抬高到与肘部齐平，并向腹部靠拢。它们被连续几次猛烈地抽动。随后，这些器械静止了。火焰咆哮着。
People flung into the flames pearls, gold vases, cups, torches, all their wealth. The offerings became constantly more numerous and more splendid. At last, a man who tottered, a man pale and hideous with terror, thrust forward a child. Then a little black mass was seen between the hands of the colossus and sank into the dark opening. The priests bent over the edge of the great flagstone and a new song burst forth celebrating the joys of death and of new birth into eternity. The children ascended slowly and as the smoke formed lofty eddies as it escaped, they seemed, at a distance, to disappear in a cloud.
人们将珍珠、金瓶、杯子、火把，以及他们所有的财富抛入火中。祭品变得越来越丰富、越来越壮观。最后，一个步履蹒跚、脸色苍白、因恐惧而显得狰狞的男人推着一个孩子走上前去。接着，人们看到巨像的手中出现了一团黑色的小东西，沉入了黑暗的开口中。祭司们俯身在巨大的石板边缘，一首庆祝死亡与永生重生的新歌爆发出来。孩子们缓缓上升，随着烟雾在逃逸时形成高耸的漩涡，从远处看，他们仿佛消失在云雾之中。
The brazen arms were working quickly now. Nevertheless, the appetite of the god was not appeased. He ever wished for more. In order to furnish him with a larger supply, the victims were piled up on his hands with a big chain above them which kept them in their place. It was impossible to distinguish them in the giddy motion of their horrible arms. This lasted for a long, indefinite time until the evening. Then the partitions inside assumed a darker glow and burning flesh could be seen. Some even believed that they could descry hair, limbs and whole bodies. So Tom, that is by Gustave Flaubert, the author of Madame Bovary. It's a very different book. It's his book Salonbo, which was published in 1862. Very much not set in
青铜手臂现在运作得很快。然而，神的胃口并没有得到满足。他总是想要更多。为了给他提供更多的祭品，受害者们被堆叠在他的手上，上面压着一条大铁链将他们固定在原位。在那些恐怖手臂令人眩晕的动作中，根本无法分辨出他们。这种情况持续了很长一段时间，直到傍晚。随后，内部的隔板呈现出更深的光泽，可以看到燃烧的血肉。有些人甚至认为他们能辨认出头发、四肢和完整的躯体。这就是古斯塔夫·福楼拜（《包法利夫人》的作者）所写的《萨朗波》。这是一本非常不同的书，出版于1862年。它绝非以法国外省为背景。
provincial France. No, not the story of a young woman who's been reading too much in French romantic periodicals. This is very different. This is set in Carthage. And I remember reading this when I was at university and being stunned that it was so different from Madame Bovary, because what Salambeau does is it plunges you into this incredibly violent, lurid, Orientalist fantasy of ancient Carthage, doesn't it? It does. And this is set against a very particular episode. And it's not one of the most famous episodes in Carthaginian history. It directly follows on from the first great war that the Carthaginians fought against the Romans, the first Punic War, as it's called. And the Carthaginians have been defeated and they've had to pay reparations to the Romans. And as a result, they can't pay their
不，这不是一个读了太多法国浪漫主义期刊的年轻女人的故事。这完全不同。故事背景设定在迦太基。我记得在大学时读过这本书，并对它与《包法利夫人》的巨大差异感到震惊，因为《萨朗波》将你带入了一个极其暴力、耸人听闻、充满东方主义幻想的古迦太基，不是吗？确实如此。而且故事背景设定在一个非常特殊的时期。这并不是迦太基历史上最著名的事件之一。它紧接着迦太基人与罗马人进行的第一场大战，即所谓的第一次布匿战争。迦太基人战败了，不得不向罗马人支付赔款。结果，他们无法支付雇佣军的薪水，
mercenaries, which they've been employing to conduct the war. And so the mercenaries have turned on Carthage and put it under siege. And it looks like the city may be about to be captured. And the great Carthaginian general, the commander who had remained undefeated in the war against the Romans, Hamilcar Barca, has been summoned to join the rest of the Carthaginian elite to pay the ultimate sacrifice, which is to give their firstborn to the great god Moloch. So it is the god Moloch whose hands have been moving up and down with the great golden chain. It's very Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom, isn't it? I mean, it's the sacrifice scene in the Temple of Doom. Yes, it is. And that, of course, I guess, would be playing on exactly this scene. And Hamilcar does not want to sacrifice his son called Hannibal. And so he has got a slave boy
而这些雇佣军正是他们雇来打仗的。于是，雇佣军反戈一击，围困了迦太基。城市似乎即将陷落。迦太基伟大的将军，那位在对罗马战争中保持不败的指挥官汉尼拔·巴卡（Hamilcar Barca），被召集去与迦太基的其他精英一起做出终极牺牲，即将他们的长子献给伟大的神摩洛克（Moloch）。所以，正是摩洛克神的手臂随着那条巨大的金链上下移动。这非常有《印第安纳·琼斯与魔宫传奇》的感觉，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是《魔宫传奇》里的祭祀场景。是的，确实如此。当然，我想这正是借鉴了这一场景。汉尼拔不想牺牲他的儿子，那个叫汉尼拔的孩子，所以他找了一个奴隶男孩，
instead and swapped them. And of course, this means that Hamilcar's son Hannibal survives. And Hannibal will go on to grow up and become the most famous of all Carthaginians. The man who leads elephants over the Alps brings Rome almost to its knees. And the story of Hannibal's war against the Romans is probably the most famous war actually in the whole of ancient history. But we are not going to be focusing on Hannibal's war, but on the early history of Carthage in this series. So Tom, that war that you described with the mercenaries, that's 238 BC. So we'll be getting sort of towards that, but just on the Orientalism and whatnot of Carthage. So even people who know nothing about ancient history will have heard the name, won't
取而代之。当然，这意味着汉尼拔的儿子汉尼拔活了下来。汉尼拔长大后成为了所有迦太基人中最著名的一位。那个带领大象翻越阿尔卑斯山，几乎让罗马屈膝的人。汉尼拔对罗马的战争可能是整个古代历史上最著名的战争。但在这个系列中，我们不会专注于汉尼拔的战争，而是关注迦太基的早期历史。那么汤姆，你描述的那场与雇佣军的战争发生在公元前238年。所以我们将会接近那个时间点，但关于迦太基的东方主义等等。所以即使是对古代历史一无所知的人，也会听说过这个名字，不是吗？
they? I mean, there are Carthages in the United States, for example, named after the city. And I guess the reputation of Carthage, even among people who don't know much about it, is that Rome is disciplined, formidable, clean-shaven, all of that stuff. And Carthage is exotic, cruel, luxurious, decadent. Yes. As you said, unbelievably cruel. Child sacrifice is obviously a massive element of that. These incredibly weird and terrifying gods, but also rich and entrepreneurial.
我的意思是，在美国就有以这座城市命名的迦太基。我想，即使在对它了解不多的人心中，迦太基的形象也是：罗马是纪律严明、强大、面容整洁的，而迦太基则是异国情调、残忍、奢华、颓废的。是的。正如你所说，难以置信的残忍。活人祭祀显然是其中一个巨大的要素。这些极其怪异和可怕的神灵，但同时也富有且具有商业头脑。
So the French, after the French Revolution, when they thought that they were the Romans, they used to say that the British were the Carthaginians because all we cared about was making money. But also because Carthage was a great maritime power. And of course, Rome is a great land power. And so their war was often characterized as the war between the elephant and the whale, that kind of thing. And so the French were very keen to brand the British as Carthaginian, both because they were seen as being treacherous mercantilists, but also, of course, because ultimately Carthage loses and gets obliterated, but is commemorated by the Romans as her greatest enemy. And Hannibal is seen as the most forbiddable opponent that the Romans
所以法国大革命后，当法国人认为自己是罗马人时，他们常说英国人是迦太基人，因为我们只关心赚钱。但也因为迦太基是一个伟大的海上强国。当然，罗马是一个伟大的陆地强国。因此，他们的战争常被描述为大象与鲸鱼之间的战争，诸如此类。所以法国人非常热衷于给英国人贴上迦太基人的标签，既因为他们被视为背信弃义的重商主义者，也因为最终迦太基战败并被抹去，但被罗马人铭记为他们最强大的敌人。汉尼拔被视为罗马人所面对过的最可怕的对手。
ever fought. And so that's a crucial part of why the memory of Carthage endures. And so we'll be covering the first of those great wars in the fourth of Carthage endures. And so we'll be covering the first of those great wars in the fourth of our episodes. But before that, we want to look at what the origins are of Carthage. What's the characteristics of our civilization? Did they really sacrifice their children or is that just kind of Roman propaganda? To try and kind of bring back to life this extraordinary civilization, which has been, I think, kind of blackened so repeatedly over the course of history. And Tom, just for people who don't know, so Carthage is effectively on the site
所以，这就是迦太基的记忆得以长存的关键原因。我们将在第四集中讲述那些伟大战争中的第一场。但在那之前，我们想看看迦太基的起源是什么。我们文明的特征是什么？他们真的祭祀自己的孩子吗，还是那只是某种罗马宣传？试图让这个非凡的文明重现生机，我认为它在历史上被反复抹黑。汤姆，对于那些不知道的人，迦太基实际上位于现今北非突尼斯共和国的首都突尼斯市。几乎所有的遗迹，如果你去过突尼斯，我也去过，我其实觉得有点失望，因为除了你那一点点石头，古迦太基的几乎每一处痕迹都被抹去了。好吧，我们一会儿再谈这个，但这并不是我们第一次做关于迦太基的节目。在世界杯期间，我们做过一期。当时突尼斯队正在参加世界杯。所以我们那一集是关于迦太基的建立，这是一个著名的传说，因为它被维吉尔写进了《埃涅阿斯纪》。它描述了埃涅阿斯，一位逃离特洛伊的王子，被神灵注定要去意大利，他们的父亲，
of present-day Tunis, the capital of Tunisia in North Africa. And almost all the traces, I mean, if you've ever been to Tunis, I've been to Tunis, I actually thought it was a bit disappointing because almost every single trace of ancient Carthage, apart from your little bit of stone, has been erased. Well, we might come to that in a minute, but this isn't the first episode that we've done on Carthage. So in the World Cup, we did one. Tunisia were playing in the World Cup. And so our episode was on the founding of Carthage, which is a kind of famous legend because it was enshrined by Virgil in the Aeneid. It described how Aeneas, who is a prince fleeing Troy, who is fated by the gods to go to Italy and their father,
那条最终导致罗马建立的国王血统。但他停留在现在的突尼斯，在那里他看到了一位来自提尔（Tyre）城的女性建立了一座城市。这个女人叫狄多（Dido），也被称为埃莉萨（Elissa）。她来自现在的黎巴嫩。在古代，那里被称为迦南。所以她是一位提尔公主。故事是这样的——这不是维吉尔记载中的情节，但被希腊和罗马历史学家反复讲述——她嫁给了她的叔叔，一个叫阿克巴斯（Akerbas）的人。狄多的兄弟，一个叫皮格马利翁（Pygmalion）的人，是提尔的国王，他非常嫉妒阿克巴斯，因为阿克巴斯太有钱了。于是他谋杀了阿克巴斯。然后他想夺取阿克巴斯的财富。
the line of kings that will culminate in the founding of Rome. But he stops off in what is now Tunisia, and he sees there the founding of a city by a woman from a city called Tyre. And this woman is called Dido, but she's also known as Elissa. And she has come from what is now Lebanon. So in ancient times, it was called Canaan. So she is a Tyrian princess. And the story goes, and this is a story that doesn't feature in Virgil's account, but was kind of repeatedly told by Greek and Roman historians, that she had been married to her uncle, a guy called Akerbas. And Dido's brother, a man called Pygmalion, was the king of Tyre, was very, very jealous of Akerbas because Akerbas was so rich. And so he has Akerbis murdered. And he then wants to seize Akerbis' wealth.
但在他得手之前，狄多把金子装进袋子里扔进海里，以此作为对神的祭献。但实际上，多米尼克，袋子里装的是沙子，而不是金子。真是个了不起的诡计，汤姆。她拿走了金子，航行向西去建立迦太基。这显然是一个神话。我的意思是，它充满了神话色彩。但有趣的是，在古典名字中存在着真实的提尔名字的回响。比如皮格马利翁（Pomeaton）、埃莉萨（Elissa）、狄多（Elishat）和阿克巴斯（Zakabal）。
But before he can do that, Dido makes an offering of it to the gods by putting all the gold into sacks and throwing it into the sea. But in fact, Dominic, the sacks are full of sand, not gold. What an amazing trick, Tom. And she has taken the gold and she sails off, heads west to found Carthage. And this is clearly a myth. I mean, it has a myth all over it. But what's intriguing is that there are echoes of authentic Tyrian names in the classical names. So Pygmalion, Pomeaton, Elissa, Dido, Elishat, and Akerbis, Zakabal.
这些名字似乎确实来自真正的提尔来源。当然，还有那件把金子扔掉、作为祭品献给神的事情，这在《萨朗波》中也有所呼应。在他们开始祭祀孩子之前，他们正把珠宝、项链和金子扔进火焰中。所以也许那里确实有一些元素。有一点是绝对肯定的，那就是迦太基确实是由来自提尔的殖民者建立的。来自黎巴嫩。是的。所以就是黎巴嫩的那座城市。我们从希罗多德记载的一个非常著名的细节中得知这一点。
These names do seem to come from genuinely Tyrian sources. And the other thing, of course, that thing of throwing gold away, of making it as an offering to the gods, I mean, that is kind of echoed a little bit in Salambo. Before they start sacrificing the children, they are hurling in their jewels and their necklaces and their gold to the flames. So perhaps there's kind of elements there. And one thing that is absolutely certain is that Carthage really was founded by colonists from Tyre. From Lebanon. Yes. So the city in Lebanon. And we know this from a very famous detail that is recorded by
提尔最终被波斯国王征服，居鲁士大帝的儿子，所有波斯国王中最强大的一位，一个叫冈比西斯（Cambyses）的人，他征服了埃及。然后他想继续向西征服迦太基。为了做到这一点，他需要提尔舰队的协助，因为提尔是一座伟大的水手之城。提尔人拒绝参与，理由是迦太基人是他们的孩子，而且迦太基人仍然会来到提尔进行祭献。事实上，多米尼克，你还记得亚历山大大帝后来围攻并占领了提尔。
Herodotus. So Tyre ends up being conquered by the Persian kings and the son of Cyrus the Great, the first and most formidable of all the Persian kings, a guy called Cambyses, he conquers Egypt. Then he wants to press on westwards and conquer Carthage. To do that, he needs the assistance of a Tyrian fleet, because Tyre is a great city of sailors. The Tyrians refuse to participate on the basis that the Carthaginians are their children and that the Carthaginians still come to Tyre to make offerings. And in fact, Dominic, you'll remember that Alexander the Great goes on to besiege Tyre and to capture it.
他确实做到了。故事是说，当他占领提尔时，那里有一支迦太基大使代表团，他们是来向提尔进行祭献的。哦，真好。迦太基和提尔之间有一种特殊的关系，汤姆。一种特殊的关系。我们从希腊文献中知道这一点，但我们也从迦太基文献中知道。实际上，迦太基确实有一些东西留存了下来。并非一切都被摧毁了。有很多铭文，在这些铭文中，你会读到关于“提尔之子”的记载，称迦太基人为提尔之子。
He does, yeah. And the story goes is that when he captures Tyre, there is a contingent of Carthaginian ambassadors there who've come to make offerings to Tyre. Oh, nice. A special relationship, Tom, between Carthage and Tyre. A special relationship. We know that from the Greek sources, but we also know it from Carthaginian sources. Actually, things have survived from Carthage. Not everything was destroyed. There are quite a lot of inscriptions, and on these inscriptions, you will read references to sons of Tyre, to the Carthaginians
我想这有点像说你的祖先是乘“五月花号”来的，即使在公元前二世纪，能够声称拥有提尔血统也是一种真正的地位标志。是的，这说得通。所以我认为要了解迦太基，我们首先需要了解提尔。当然。这就是今天这一集的主题。所以提尔既是极其古老的，又是一个暴发户。最早关于它的记载是在公元前19世纪。所以那几乎是4000年前的事了。但相对于现在黎巴嫩海岸的其他城市，它实际上是一个相当的暴发户。所以我们有比布鲁斯（Byblos），这座城市为希腊语中的“书”一词提供了词源，并最终演变为“圣经”（Bible）；还有西顿（Sidon），它是它的近邻和竞争对手。这些都比提尔古老得多，但提尔在公元前二千纪开始出现在舞台上时，它拥有很多优势。因此，它很快就接管了那些更古老的城市。原因在于它拥有许多自然优势。它坐落在一个离岸约半英里的岛屿上。它有一块可以作为堡垒的岩石。它有淡水，所以它有泉水，
as sons of Tyre. I suppose a bit like saying that your ancestors came over with the Mayflower, that to be able to claim a Tyrian heritage, even in the second century BC, is a real marker of status. Yeah, that makes sense. So I think that to know about Carthage, we first of all need to know about Tyre. Sure. And so that is going to be the subject of today's episode. So Tyre is simultaneously fabulously ancient and a parvenu. The earliest reference to it is the 19th century BC. So that's almost kind of 4,000 years ago. But relative to other cities on the coast of what's
因此它可以获得补给并抵御围攻。它有两个伟大的天然港口，在它的历史进程中得到了相当大的增强。而且它有一个相当肥沃的腹地。黎巴嫩大陆的土壤非常肥沃。但问题是，它无法像埃及、亚述或巴比伦那样扩张成为一个大帝国，因为它向东的扩张被黎巴嫩山脉阻挡了。所有这些城市都是如此。是的，那是一片相当狭窄的地带，不是吗？你可以耕种之类的地方，然后就到了山脉。是的。正因为如此，它们周期性地受到该地区大国的影响。首先是埃及，随后是亚述和巴比伦。提尔以及黎巴嫩沿岸其他城市所扮演的角色本质上是水手，他们出去寻找原材料，然后将其加工成高端产品，再转卖或作为贡品交给埃及人、亚述人或其他任何人。为了做到这一点，他们需要发展航海技能。他们可以做到这一点，部分是因为他们必须这样做，但也因为他们有很多木材。雪松。他们拥有黎巴嫩的雪松，著名的黎巴嫩雪松。如果没有这些，他们就会像埃及或美索不达米亚那样缺乏木材。但因为他们拥有这些，
now Lebanon, it's actually quite a parvenu. So we have Byblos, which is the city that gives its name to the Greek word for book and ultimately to the Bible. And Sidos, which is the city that gives its name to the Greek word for book and ultimately to the Bible, and Sidon, which is its near neighbor, arrival. And these are much older than Tyre, but Tyre, when it starts to emerge on the scene in the second millennium BC, it has a lot of advantages going for it. And so it very rapidly comes to take over the older cities. So the reason for this is that it has a lot of natural advantages. It's situated on an island about half a mile off the shore. It's got a rock which can serve it as a fortress. It's got fresh water, so it's got springs,
而且因为他们别无选择，只能出海谋生，他们非常迅速地将航海的极限推向了比任何人都远的地方。所以，早在公元前三千纪，比布鲁斯的人民就开始开发带有弯曲船体的船只，而埃及人，例如，只有平底船。所以基本上从未真正掌握冒险进入地中海的艺术。但黎巴嫩人民确实做到了这一点。正是这一点使他们能够在公元前12世纪那场压垮了青铜时代真正强大势力的巨大灾难中幸存下来，这被称为“青铜时代崩溃”，当时本质上是一群神秘的被称为“海上民族”的人，也许在某个时候我们会做一期关于他们的节目，他们跨越海洋，埃及几乎陷落，各种主要势力都倒下了。其中之一是乌加里特（Ugarat）城，它是提尔的邻居。那座城市被摧毁了。提尔幸存了下来。于是黎巴嫩的城市，特别是提尔，获得了一段喘息的空间，因为埃及和美索不达米亚帝国都相当虚弱。所以提尔人可以走出去，他们拥有所有这些海军专业知识，而且他们不需要支付贡品。所以这确实是提尔的黄金时代。所以他们走出去，获取原材料，回来，带到作坊，原材料被加工，然后他们特意
so it can be supplied and withstand a siege. It's got two great natural harbors, which are considerably enhanced over the course of its history. And it has quite a fertile hinterland. So the soil of mainland Lebanon is very fertile. But the problem is that it can't expand to become a great empire in the way that, say, Egypt had or Assyria or Babylon will, because its expansion eastwards is blocked by the great range of Mount Lebanon. And this is true of all the cities. Yeah, it's quite a narrow stretch, isn't it, where you can sort of farm and stuff, and then you get to the mountains. Yeah. And because of this, they periodically come under the influence of the great powers in the region. So Egypt in particular to begin with, and then in
为外国市场制造产品。所以他们用埃及风格或美索不达米亚风格建造东西，然后卖掉。所以这些人是工匠、贸易商、中间人、商人。我想这就是你们典型的中东、黎凡特海上强国，不是吗？是的。我想这在某种程度上类似于20世纪香港对中国的角色。或者之前的新加坡。或者新加坡。就是那种角色。我的意思是，这非常不合时宜，我想，但它给你一种感觉。现在，你可能想知道我们是怎么知道这些的。考古证据非常非常稀少，因为提尔被摧毁并重建了太多次。我们确实有国王名单，由公元一世纪的犹太作家约瑟夫斯（Josephus）保存了下来。但我的意思是，你知道，那是一千年后的事了，所以不完全可靠。但我们确实有关于提尔古代历史的来源。哦，那太令人兴奋了。其中之一就是我们已经提到的那本书，即《圣经》。哦，汤姆，你真爱它。
due course, Assyria and Babylonia. And the role that Tyre and the other cities along Lebanon play is essentially that of sailors, people who go out and source material, raw material, which they then turn into kind of high-end products, which they then sell on or pay as tribute to the Egyptians or to the Assyrians or whoever. And so to do this, they need to develop maritime skills. And they can do this partly because they have to, but also because they have a lot of wood. Cedars. They have the cedars of Lebanon, the famous cedars of Lebanon. And so without that, they would be as denuded of timber as Egypt is or Mesopotamia. But because they have that,
我们爱《圣经》。在《列王纪》中，描述了以色列王国在其黄金时代的崛起，即大卫和所罗门时期，提尔国王，一个叫希兰（Hiram）的人，扮演了非常关键的角色。大卫占领了耶路撒冷。他正在为建造他的伟大圣殿铺平道路。他想建造一座宫殿，但没有提尔人拥有的原材料和专业知识。于是他们达成了一项协议，基本上是大卫允许提尔商人进入红海，作为回报，希兰将提供木材、材料和工匠给大卫。真正开始产生巨大影响是在大卫的儿子所罗门统治时期，因为当然，所罗门想建造圣殿并确实做到了。正如《圣经》告诉我们的，没有希兰的协助，他是不可能做到这一点的。
and because they have no choice but to go out and earn their keep on the waters, they very, very rapidly push the limits of navigation further than they've been pushed by anyone else. So, I mean, as early as the third millennium, the people of Byblos are developing ships with kind of curved hulls, whereas the Egyptians, for instance, had only had flat hulls. So basically never really mastered the art of venturing out into the Mediterranean. But the people of Lebanon are really doing this. And it's this that enables them to survive the great catastrophe that overwhelms the really formidable Bronze Age powers in the 12th century, which is called the Bronze Age Collapse, when essentially mysterious
而希兰得到的回报是坐落在海边的城市总是需要的，那就是种植自己食物的可能性。所以所罗门卖给希兰一些拥有优良农业条件的城市，所以他们双方都受益了。因此，《圣经》详细介绍了这意味着什么。所以所罗门建造了一支红海舰队，我引用《列王纪》的话：“希兰派他自己的军官指挥的船只，那些熟悉大海的人。这些船只与所罗门的船员一起航行到俄斐（Ophir），带回了450他连得金子，交给了所罗门王。”现在，我们已经在我们的一集节目中触及了这些探险，即《所罗门王的宝藏》，因为俄斐的位置是一个巨大的谜。当然，赖德·哈格德（Ryder Haggard）把它定位在非洲。我们知道它是一个真实的地方，因为1946年发现了一块陶片，大约是公元前8世纪左右，提到了它。所以它确实存在。可能不是非洲，也许是阿拉伯、印度或斯里兰卡。我的意思是，所有这些都被提议过。我们可能永远不会知道。但这给人一种兴奋感，一种感觉，外面有新的可能性和财富的世界，而提尔人想要其中的一部分。我的意思是，不仅仅是一部分，他们想要很多。当然，提尔可以直接进入地中海。
people called the Sea Peoples, and at some point we might do an episode on them, they cross the seas, Egypt almost falls, all kinds of major powers do fall. One of them is a city called Ugarat, which is a neighbor of Tyre. That gets destroyed. Tyre survives. And there's a kind of breathing space then for the cities of Lebanon, particularly for Tyre, because both Egypt and the Mesopotamian empires are pretty prostrate. And so the Tyrians can go out there, they have all this kind of naval expertise, and they don't need to pay tribute. And so really, this is the kind of the golden age, really, of Tyre. So they're going out, they're getting raw materials, they're coming back, they are taking it to workshops, the raw materials are being processed, and they're then deliberately
《圣经》告诉我们，所罗门和希兰也派遣舰队穿越地中海。他们前往一个神秘的地方叫他施（Tarshish），一支伟大的舰队。每三年，这支舰队就会返回。我再次引用《圣经》：“载着金子、银子、象牙、猿猴和狒狒。”同样，他施的位置也不确定。人们建议它可能是撒丁岛，或者可能是越过直布罗陀海峡、赫拉克勒斯之柱，一个由提尔人建立的定居点叫加德斯（Gardes），它后来成为了西班牙城市加的斯（Cadiz）。但更有可能的是一个叫他施的地方，它大致相当于今天的安达卢西亚，即西班牙南部。
making it for foreign markets. So they're constructing things in Egyptian styles or Mesopotamian styles, flogging it on. So these people are craftsmen, traders, middlemen, merchants. I guess your classic kind of Middle Eastern, Levantine maritime power, aren't they? Yes. I suppose serving a role slightly analogous to maybe Hong Kong did to China in the 20th century. Or Singapore before that. Or Singapore. It's that kind of thing, that kind of role. I mean, that's very anachronistic, I guess, but it gives you some kind of flavor. Now, you may be wondering how we know about this. Archaeological evidence is very, very sparse because Tyre has been destroyed and built
好的。那么汤姆，如果提尔人与《圣经》中的人物有所有这些接触，那么是否也有宗教接触、文化接触之类的事情，比如神灵、仪式以及所有那些融入后来犹太教的东西？是的，有相似之处，因为以色列人和迦南人，正如提尔人可能描述自己的那样，他们非常亲近。正是因为他们亲近，使得这些故事的作者——这些故事是在许多世纪后写成的——对提尔人感到焦虑。所以对提尔确实有钦佩之情。不仅在《列王纪》中，以赛亚书和以西结书中，他们都被提尔的财富所震惊。那种本质上财富本身在某种程度上就是提尔的感觉。所以伟大的古代历史学家弗格斯·米勒（Fergus Miller）指出，在耶路撒冷，直到圣殿的最后日子，圣殿里支付的标准货币是提尔舍客勒。所以，我的意思是，这有力地证明了提尔作为贸易和财富模式的重要性。但你是对的，也有巨大的焦虑原因。所以摩洛克这个名字，
over so many times. We do have king lists, which have been preserved by Josephus, the Judean writer in the first century AD. But I mean, you know, that's a thousand years on, so not entirely reliable. But we do have sources for the ancient history of Tyre. Oh, that's exciting. And one of them is nothing less than the book we've already mentioned, which is the Bible. Oh, Tom, you love it.
福楼拜在他的小说中借鉴了这个名字，它来自《圣经》。我们在《圣经》中被告知，所罗门为摩洛克建造了一座圣殿，他被描述为“可憎的神”。我们后来也被告知，摩洛克在耶路撒冷外的一个山谷里有他的圣所，这个圣所位于一个叫陀斐特（Tophet）的特定地方。这个陀斐特被描述为一个人们祭祀的地方，我引用《圣经》的话：“他们的儿女献给摩洛克的火。”就像福楼拜的书《萨朗波》里一样，就像迦太基人一样。完全就像福楼拜的书里一样。
We love the Bible. So in the book of Kings, which describes the rise of the kingdom of Israel in its golden age, so David and Solomon, the king of Tyre, a man called Hiram, plays a very key role. So David has captured Jerusalem. He is preparing the way to build his great temple. He wants to build a palace, doesn't have the raw materials and the expertise that the people of Tyre have. And so they kind of strike a deal, basically, that David will allow Tyrian merchants access to the Red Sea, and in return, Hiram will give wood and material and craftsmen to David. It's really in the reign of David's son, Solomon, that this starts to pack a massive punch because, of course, Solomon wants to build the temple and does so. He couldn't have done this, so the Bible tells us, without the assistance of
我们也同样被告知，犹大国的两位国王在那里将他们的儿子献给雅威（Yahweh），大概是在去打仗前将他们献在火中，这绝对是《萨朗波》中场景的回响。虽然这并没有明确与提尔联系起来，但在希兰和所罗门共同建造圣殿的辉煌日子之后，也有一种感觉，提尔的声誉正在变暗。这种声誉的变暗集中在一个特定的女人身上，她是公元前九世纪提尔国王伊托巴尔（Ithabal）的女儿。这个女人就是耶洗别（Jezebel）。啊，我一直在想我们什么时候会提到耶洗别。现在，她是一个伟大的人物，汤姆。她是。我的意思是，她已经变成了一个名词。她确实是。所以“涂脂抹粉的耶洗别”。所以一个名声不好的女人，一个诱惑者，一个引诱人们偏离正道的人。有趣的是，多米尼克，根据
Hiram. And what Hiram gets in return is what a city perched on the edge of the sea always needs, which is the possibility to grow its own food. So Solomon sells Hiram some cities that have excellent agriculture, so both of them benefit. And so the Bible goes into some detail about what this means in practical terms. So Solomon builds a Red Sea fleet, and I'll quote from the Book of Kings, and Hiram sent him ships commanded by his own officers, men who knew the sea. These, with Solomon's men, sailed to Ophir and brought back 450 talents of gold, which they delivered to King Solomon. Now, we have touched on these expeditions already in one of our episodes, namely King Solomon's mines, because the location of Ophir
同样是公元一世纪写作的约瑟夫斯的说法，她是狄多的姨妈。所以这是一个精彩的交叉。是的，迦太基电影宇宙，汤姆。正是如此。所以根据《圣经》，耶洗别嫁给了以色列国王亚哈（Ahab）。这是《圣经》中著名的段落之一，亚哈致力于巴力（Baal），并因此遭到两位伟大的先知，以色列先知以利亚（Elijah）和以利沙（Elisha）的反对。当然，圣经作者讨厌这一点。他们讨厌以色列国王可能被巴力崇拜所诱惑的想法。所以亚哈死后，以利沙来到一位以色列战车军官叫耶户（Jehu）面前，并膏他为王。耶户
is a great mystery. And of course, Ryder Haggard situates it in Africa. And we know that it's a real place because a fragment of pottery was found in 1946, kind of 8th century BC, sometime like that, which makes a reference to it. So it definitely existed. Probably not Africa, maybe Arabia or India or Sri Lanka. I mean, all of those have been proposed. We'll probably never know. But it kind of gives a sense of the excitement of it, the sense that there are new worlds of possibility and wealth out there and that the Tyrians want a bit of it. I mean, more than a bit of it, they want a lot of it. And of course, Tyre has direct access to the Mediterranean.
坐上他的战车，《圣经》说他疯狂地驾驶。他杀死了亚哈的儿子们，他们分别是以色列国王和犹大国王。然后他去找耶洗别。耶洗别看到他过来，她装饰了她的头发，涂了脂粉，穿上她最好的长袍，从窗户向下看着耶户，谴责他是他主人的谋杀者。耶户抬头看到她被太监包围，命令太监：“把她扔下来。”太监们知道哪边的面包涂了黄油。
And the Bible tells us that Solomon and Hiram are also sending fleets across the Mediterranean. And they travel to a mysterious place called Tarshish, a great fleet. And every three years, this fleet would return. And I quote the Bible again, carrying gold, silver and ivory and apes and baboons. Again, the location of Tarshish is uncertain. People have suggested it might be Sardinia or perhaps going beyond the Straits of Gibraltar, the Pillars of Hercules, a settlement founded by the Tyrians called Gardes, which will go on to become the Spanish city of Cadiz. But more likely it's a place called Tarshish, which kind of approximates to Andalusia today, so southern
于是他们确实把她扔了下来。然后《圣经》说耶户进去吃喝。“照顾那个被诅咒的女人，”他说，“埋葬她，因为她是国王的女儿。”所以他的仆人出去寻找耶洗别的尸体并埋葬它。但他们只找到了她的头骨、脚和手。其余的部分都被狗吃了。这就是以利亚所预言的诅咒的实现，即耶洗别会被狗吃掉。这是一个伟大的故事。我跟你说实话。当我在学校学习《圣经》时，
Spain. Okay. So Tom, if the Tyrians are having all this contact with the people of the Bible, are there kind of religious contacts and things, cultural contacts and things like that as well, like gods and rituals and all of that stuff that kind of feeds into what becomes Judaism? Yes, there are congruities because the Israelites and the people of Canaan, as the people of Tyre would have probably described themselves, they're very close. And it's precisely the fact that they are close that makes the writers of these stories, and these stories are being written many centuries later, anxious about the Tyrians. So there's definitely admiration for Tyre. It's not just in the Book of Kings, but Isaiah and Ezekiel, they are stupefied by the wealth
在时光的迷雾中——你是耶洗别队的，是吗？我只是觉得这是一个精彩的故事。我想我写过一篇关于那个故事的文章，甚至可能是一篇带插图的文章。我只是认为人们被狗吃掉总是很好的票房。有一些很棒的插图。总之，在《圣经》中，你得到了对提尔的钦佩和对她的敌意的混合。你在其他见证提尔荣耀的古代民族的著作中也得到了同样的东西，那就是希腊人。所以这有点像波斯。基本上，我们得到的关于波斯的叙述来自希腊人和《圣经》记载。提尔人民也是如此。提尔在希腊神话中扮演着非常重要的角色，因为欧罗巴（Europa）公主，她为欧洲大陆命名，来自
of Tyre. The sense that essentially treasure itself is in some way Tyrian. So Fergus Miller, the great ancient historian, he pointed out that in Jerusalem, right up to the final days of the temple, the standard currency that's being paid in the temple is Tyrian shekels. So, I mean, that's kind of massive witness to just how significant Tyre is as a kind of model of trade and wealth. But you're right that there are also huge causes for anxiety. So the name Moloch,
提尔。她是一位美丽的公主。她有一个父亲，通常叫阿格诺尔（Agenor），但在一些记载中叫凤凰（Phoenix）。欧罗巴正在海滩上玩耍。一头巨大的白牛出现了。欧罗巴爬上牛背。牛游向大海，欧罗巴消失了。这头牛，结果证明是宙斯。但阿格诺尔或凤凰，无论你想怎么称呼他，都不知道这一点。于是他派他的儿子们去寻找欧罗巴。这些儿子中最著名的是一个叫卡德摩斯（Cadmus）的人，他最终前往希腊。在那里他杀死了一条龙。雅典娜告诉他播种龙的牙齿。人从这些牙齿中长出来。
which Flaubert draws on for his novel, this comes from the Bible. And we're told in the Bible that Solomon builds a temple to Moloch, who is described as the detestable God. And we're told also later on that Moloch has a sanctuary to him in a valley outside Jerusalem, and that this sanctuary is in a particular place called Tophet. And this Tophet is described as a place where men sacrifice, and I will quote the Bible, their sons and daughters to the fire of Moloch. Like in Flaubert's book, Salambo, like the Carthaginians. Exactly like in Flaubert's book.
卡德摩斯向他们扔了一块石头。他们都开始互相碰撞，互相砍杀，倒在彼此的剑下。只有五个神秘的人幸存下来，他们帮助卡德摩斯建立了一座非常非常著名的希腊城市，即底比斯（Thebes）。底比斯的卫城被称为卡德米亚（Cadmea）。在他生命的尽头，卡德摩斯和他的王后变成了蛇。所以这一切听起来很疯狂。不可思议，汤姆，我会说。不可思议。但在希腊人的观点中，欧罗巴和卡德摩斯的故事在某种意义上是历史的绝对源头，因为正是从欧罗巴开始，希罗多德
And we are told as well that two kings of Judah offer up their sons to Yahweh there, offering them up presumably in the fire before going to war, which absolutely is a kind of echo of the scene in Salambo. And although this isn't explicitly associated with Tyre, there is also a sense after the kind of the glory days of Hiram and Solomon building the temple together, that Tyre's reputation is darkening. And this darkening of the reputation is focused on a particular woman who is the daughter of a king of Tyre in the ninth century called Ithabal. And this woman is Jezebel. Ah, and I wondered if we get to Jezebel. Now, she's a great character, Tom. She is. I mean, she's become a noun. She has. So a painted Jezebel. So a woman of ill repute, a seductress, someone who lures people off the straight and narrow. Intriguingly, Dominic, according to
开始了《历史》，这是我们拥有的第一部历史著作，因为他试图合理化这个神话。他说实际上不是宙斯绑架了欧罗巴，而是希腊商人。他们这样做是因为提尔商人绑架了一位希腊公主。所以有一种相互的公主抢夺。这最终导致了特洛伊的陷落，随后是波斯对希腊的入侵。所以那是坏的，提尔表现得很坏，但也有积极的一面，因为希罗多德将一个非常非常重大的创新归功于卡德摩斯，没有它他就无法
Josephus again, writing in the first century AD, she was the great aunt of Dido. So it's a kind of brilliant crossover. Yeah. The Carthaginian cinematic universe, Tom. Exactly. So according to the Bible, Jezebel marries Ahab, who is the king of Israel. And it's kind of one of the famous passages in the Bible that Ahab devotes himself to Baal, and he's opposed in this by the two great prophets, the Israelite prophets, Elijah and Elisha. And of course, biblical writers hate this. They hate the idea that an Israelite king might have been seduced by the worship of Baal. And so after Ahab's death, Elisha comes to an Israelite king might have been seduced by the worship of Baal. And so after Ahab's death, Elisha comes to an Israelite chariot officer called Jehu and anoints him as king. And Jehu
写他的历史。这就是文字的发明。所以希罗多德说：“在我看来，希腊人在那之前并没有字母表。起初，字母与卡德摩斯在提尔使用的相同，但随着时间的推移，希腊语的发展，他们的文字形式也随之演变。”所以有一种感觉，这就是希腊语如何从提尔文字演变而来的。这合理吗？好吧，我们将在下半部分讨论这个问题，当我们看看这些神话和故事实际上可能告诉我们关于历史现实的什么。所以希罗多德也给了我们很多关于提尔的其他信息。他说他亲自访问过它。他说他看到了一座极其古老的圣殿，根据在那里服务的祭司的说法，它有2300年的历史。
gets in his chariot and he drives furiously, the Bible says. And he kills Ahab's sons, who are respectively the king of Israel and the king of Judah. And then he goes to find Jezebel. And Jezebel sees him coming and she adorns her hair, paints herself, puts on her finest robes, looks down at Jehu from her window and condemns him as the murderer of his master. And Jehu looks up and sees her surrounded by her eunuchs and orders the eunuchs, throw her down. And the eunuchs know which side their bread is buttered on.
所以这有点像埃及人。提尔人和埃及人把希腊人看作孩子。希罗多德说，在这座圣殿里，有两根柱子，一根是纯金的，另一根是祖母绿的，在黑暗中闪闪发光。希罗多德也证实了迦太基是由提尔建立的。所以正是从希罗多德那里，我们得到了提尔人即使在波斯国王命令下也不会航行去对抗迦太基的故事。有一种感觉，虽然提尔人承诺不与迦太基人作战，但他们非常热衷于与希腊人作战，因为在波斯国王薛西斯（Xerxes）发动的对希腊人的大战中，正是提尔人提供了关键的海军分遣队，因为他们仍然是航海大师。所以那里又有一种感觉，
And so they do throw her down. And the Bible then says that Jehu went in and ate and drank. Take care of that cursed woman, he said, and bury her, for she was a king's daughter. And so his servants go out to find Jezebel's body and bury it. But all they find is her skull, her feet, and her hands. All the rest of her has been eaten by dogs. And this is the fulfillment of a curse that had been delivered by Elijah that Jezebel would be eaten by dogs. It's a great story. I'll level with you. When I did do scripture at school,
一种希腊人和提尔人以及其他人之间的竞争。因为我应该在这一点上补充说，提尔并不是唯一一个向波斯国王提供中队并在阿耳忒弥斯（Artemisian）和萨拉米斯（Salamis）战役中作战的城市。所以希罗多德也提到了另外两个城邦的国王。其中一个是西顿，我们已经提到过，提尔北部的伟大港口。另一个是叫阿拉多斯（Arados）的港口。这些都是不同的城市，但根据希罗多德的说法，他们是一个单一的民族。所以就像雅典、斯巴达和底比斯都是希腊人一样，希罗多德假设提尔、西顿和比布鲁斯，他们都是一个单一的民族。他将这个民族命名为腓尼基人（Phoenicians）。我一直在想我们什么时候会提到腓尼基人。所以他们是以凤凰命名的，
back in the mists of time- You were team Jezebel, were you? I just thought it was a brilliant story. I think I wrote an essay on that story, maybe even an illustrated essay. I just think people being eaten by dogs is always good box office. There are some great illustrations of it. Anyway, so in the Bible, you get a mixture of admiration of Tyre and hostility to her. You also get the same in the writings of the other ancient people who bear witness to the glory of Tyre, which is the Greeks. So it's a bit like with Persia. Basically, the narratives we get about Persia come from the Greeks and biblical accounts. It's the same with the people of Tyre. And Tyre plays a very important role in Greek mythology because the princess Europa, who gives her name to the continent of Europe, comes from
对吧？他是卡德摩斯的兄弟。我没记错吧？或者可能是反过来的。所以，我的意思是，有各种各样的传统。凤凰可能是卡德摩斯的父亲。他可能是卡德摩斯的兄弟。这很混乱，因为显然他并不真正存在。好的，是的。我忘了他不真实存在了。而且可能性是他是为了解释腓尼基人是谁而被发明的。是的。
Tyre. She's a beautiful princess. She has a father, usually called Agenor, but in some accounts called Phoenix. And Europa is playing on the beach. A great white bull appears. Europa clambers onto the bull. The bull swims out to the sea and Europa vanishes. And this bull, it turns out, is Zeus. But agonor or Phoenix, whatever you want to call him, doesn't know this. And so he sends out his sons to go and find Europa. And the most famous of these sons is a guy called Cadmus, who ends up traveling to Greece. There he kills a dragon. He's told by Athena to sow the teeth of the dragon. Men grow from these teeth.
推罗。她是一位美丽的公主。她有一位父亲，通常被称为阿格诺尔，但在一些记载中被称为菲尼克斯。欧罗巴正在海滩上玩耍。一头巨大的白牛出现了。欧罗巴爬上了牛背。牛游向大海，欧罗巴消失了。事实证明，这头牛就是宙斯。但阿格诺尔或菲尼克斯，无论你想怎么称呼他，都不知道这一点。于是他派他的儿子们去寻找欧罗巴。这些儿子中最著名的是一个叫卡德摩斯的人，他最终前往希腊。在那里，他杀死了一条龙。雅典娜告诉他要播种龙的牙齿。这些人就是从这些牙齿中长出来的。
Cadmus throws a stone in among them. They all start kind of crashing into each other, chopping each other up, falling on each other's swords. Only five of these mysterious men survive, and they help Cadmus to found a very, very famous Greek city, namely Thebes. And the Acropolis of Thebes is called the Cadmea. And at the end of his life, Cadmus and his queen are turned into serpents. So this all sounds mad. Implausible, Tom, I would say. Implausible. But in the opinion of the Greeks, there's a sense in which the story of Europa and Cadmus is the absolute fountainhead of history because it is with Europa that Herodotus
卡德摩斯向他们中间扔了一块石头。他们开始互相碰撞，互相砍杀，倒在彼此的剑下。这些神秘人中只有五个人幸存下来，他们帮助卡德摩斯建立了一个非常、非常著名的希腊城市，即底比斯。底比斯的卫城被称为卡德米亚。在卡德摩斯生命的尽头，他和他的王后变成了蛇。所以这一切听起来很疯狂。汤姆，我会说这不可信。不可信。但在希腊人看来，欧罗巴和卡德摩斯的故事在某种意义上是历史的绝对源头，因为正是从欧罗巴开始，希罗多德
begins his history, the first work of history that we have, because he is trying to rationalize this myth. And he says that actually it wasn't Zeus who abducted Europa, it was Greek merchants. And they were doing it because Tyrian merchants had abducted a Greek princess. And so there's this kind of reciprocal princess rustling going on. And this culminates in the sack of Troy and then in due course with the Persian invasion of Greece. So that's bad, Tyre behaving badly, but there are also positives because Herodotus attributes to Cadmus a really major, major innovation without which he wouldn't be able
开始了《历史》的撰写，这是我们拥有的第一部历史著作，因为他试图将这个神话合理化。他说，实际上绑架欧罗巴的不是宙斯，而是希腊商人。他们这样做是因为推罗商人绑架了一位希腊公主。所以这是一种相互的公主抢夺行为。这最终导致了特洛伊的陷落，并随后导致了波斯对希腊的入侵。所以这很糟糕，推罗的行为很恶劣，但也有积极的一面，因为希罗多德将一项非常、非常重大的创新归功于卡德摩斯，没有这项创新，他就无法
to write his histories. And this is the invention of writing. So Herodotus says, the Greeks, in my opinion, had not possessed an alphabet up until that point. To begin with, the letters were the same as those Cadmus had used in Tyre, but in due course, as time went by and the language of the Greeks evolved, so too did the form of their script. So there's that sense that this is how Greek has evolved from the Tyrian script. And is that plausible? Well, we'll come to that in the second half, when we look at what these myths and stories might actually tell us about the historical reality. So Herodotus also gives us quite a lot of other information about Tyre. He says that he's visited it in person. He says that he's seen a fabulously ancient temple that according to the priests who minister there is 2,300 years old.
写下他的历史。这就是文字的发明。所以希罗多德说，在我看来，希腊人在那之前还没有字母表。起初，这些字母与卡德摩斯在推罗使用的字母相同，但随着时间的推移，随着希腊语言的演变，他们的文字形式也随之演变。所以有一种感觉，希腊文字就是这样从推罗文字演变而来的。这可信吗？好吧，我们将在下半部分讨论这个问题，届时我们将看看这些神话和故事实际上能告诉我们关于历史现实的什么。所以希罗多德还提供了很多关于推罗的其他信息。他说他亲自访问过那里。他说他看到了一座极其古老的寺庙，据在那里服务的祭司说，这座寺庙有2300年的历史。
So this is kind of a bit like the Egyptians. The Tyrians and the Egyptians look at the Greeks as children. Herodotus says that in this temple, there are two pillars, one of pure gold and the other of emerald, which gleams very brightly in the dark. And Herodotus also confirms that Carthage was founded by Tyre. So it's from Herodotus that we get the story that the people of Tyre wouldn't sail against Carthage, even when commanded to by the Persian king. And there's a sense in which, although the Tyrians are kind of committed not to fighting the Carthaginians, they're very keen about fighting the Greeks because in the great war that the Persian king Xerxes launches against the Greeks, it's the Tyrians who provide a key naval contingent because they are still master mariners. So there's a sense there, again,
所以这有点像埃及人。推罗人和埃及人把希腊人看作孩子。希罗多德说，在这座寺庙里，有两根柱子，一根是纯金的，另一根是祖母绿的，在黑暗中闪闪发光。希罗多德还证实了迦太基是由推罗建立的。所以正是从希罗多德那里，我们得到了这样一个故事：即使在波斯国王的命令下，推罗人也不会航行去对抗迦太基。在某种意义上，虽然推罗人承诺不与迦太基人作战，但他们非常热衷于与希腊人作战，因为在波斯国王薛西斯对希腊人发动的伟大战争中，正是推罗人提供了关键的海军分遣队，因为他们仍然是航海大师。所以，再次有一种感觉，
of a kind of rivalry between the Greeks and the people of Tyre and the otherers. So there's a sense there, again, of a kind of rivalry between the Greeks and the people of Tyre and the other people. Because I should add at this point that Tyre is not the only city to be providing a squadron to the Persian king and fighting at the battles of Artemisian and Salamis. So Herodotus also names the kings of two other city-states. So one of them is Sidon, which we've already mentioned, the great port north of Tyre. Another is a port called Arados. And these are all different cities, but according to Herodotus, they are a single people. So rather like, say, Athens and Sparta and Thebes are all Greeks, Herodotus assumes that Tyre and Sidon and Byblos, that they are all a single people. And he names this people as Phoenicians. I wondered if we get to the Phoenicians. So they're named after Phoenix,
希腊人和推罗人以及其他人之间存在一种竞争。所以，再次有一种感觉，希腊人和推罗人以及其他人之间存在一种竞争。因为我应该补充一点，推罗并不是唯一一个为波斯国王提供中队并在阿耳忒弥西昂和萨拉米斯战役中作战的城市。所以希罗多德还提到了其他两个城邦的国王。其中一个是西顿，我们已经提到过，它是推罗以北的大港口。另一个是叫阿拉多斯的港口。这些都是不同的城市，但根据希罗多德的说法，他们是一个单一的民族。所以就像雅典、斯巴达和底比斯都是希腊人一样，希罗多德认为推罗、西顿和比布鲁斯都是一个单一的民族。他将这个民族命名为腓尼基人。我想知道我们是否能谈到腓尼基人。所以他们是以菲尼克斯命名的，
right? Who is the brother of Cadmus. Have I got that right? Or it might be the other way around. So, I mean, there are kind of various traditions. Phoenix might be the father of Cadmus. He might be the brother of Cadmus. It's confused because obviously he didn't really exist. Okay, yeah. I'd forgotten that he didn't exist. And the likelihood is that he's invented to explain who the Phoenicians are. Yeah.
对吧？他是卡德摩斯的兄弟。我没弄错吧？或者可能是反过来的。所以，我的意思是，有各种各样的传统。菲尼克斯可能是卡德摩斯的父亲。他可能是卡德摩斯的兄弟。这很混乱，因为显然他并不真正存在。好吧，是的。我忘了他不不存在了。而且很可能他是为了解释腓尼基人是谁而被虚构出来的。是的。
Herodotus is not the first Greek author to mention the existence of Phoenicians. So Homer does. So in the Iliad, the funeral games that are held for Patroclus, the beloved of Achilles in the Iliad, the first prize in the foot race is a kind of beautiful silver mixing bowl that has been made in Sidon and brought by Phoenician merchants. He's met by Athena and he lies to Athena just because that's what Odysseus does. He always lies, even to Athena. And he claims that he's a fugitive from Crete and that he's paid passage to Phoenicians who have brought him to Ithaca. And Athena laughs because she knows that Odysseus is always lying and she loves it. So the Phoenicians are, they're kind of slightly shadowy figures in Homer, but Herodotus gives us a lot more detail.
希罗多德并不是第一位提到腓尼基人存在的希腊作家。荷马也是如此。在《伊利亚特》中，为阿喀琉斯挚爱帕特罗克洛斯举行的葬礼竞技会上，赛跑比赛的第一名奖品是一种精美的银制调酒碗，它是在西顿制造的，由腓尼基商人带来。奥德修斯遇到了雅典娜，他向雅典娜撒了谎，因为这就是奥德修斯的行事风格。他总是撒谎，即使是对雅典娜也是如此。他声称自己是来自克里特岛的逃亡者，并支付了船费给带他来到伊萨卡的腓尼基人。雅典娜笑了，因为她知道奥德修斯总是撒谎，而且她很喜欢这一点。所以，腓尼基人在荷马笔下是些略显模糊的人物，但希罗多德为我们提供了更多细节。
So he tells us that originally they came from the Red Sea. Again, he confirms that they're amazing sailors. He talks a lot about their ventures westwards into the Mediterranean, but also he tells this famous story about how a pharaoh had employed Phoenician sailors to sail down the coast of the Red Sea, keep going, and ultimately they go all the way around Africa, come up through the Straits of Gibraltar and through the Mediterranean back home. Herodotus himself says he doesn't believe this, but because he gives details about where the sun is rising that demonstrates that the Phoenicians had gone beyond the line of the
他告诉我们，他们最初来自红海。他再次证实了他们是了不起的航海家。他谈到了很多关于他们向西进入地中海的冒险经历，但也讲述了一个著名的故事：一位法老曾雇佣腓尼基水手沿着红海海岸航行，继续前行，最终他们绕过了整个非洲，穿过直布罗陀海峡，经由地中海回到了家乡。希罗多德本人说他不相信这一点，但因为他提供了关于太阳升起位置的细节，这证明了腓尼基人确实已经越过了
equator, it's clear that actually this story is true. Herodotus acknowledges that it's the Phoenicians who are the best sailors in Xerxes' fleet. Now, Greek attitudes to the Phoenicians harden in the wake of the Persian Wars, because obviously the Phoenicians have played this key role in attempting to defeat the Greeks that gets defeated at Salamis. So the Greeks hold grudges, right? They're not going to let this go. Yes, they do. Thucydides, the great historian of the Peloponnesian War, describes the Phoenicians as barbarians. He says, actually, it was the Phoenicians who'd originally settled Sicily, but then they'd been forced out by Greek colonizers. He thinks that this is absolutely tremendous. I think there's a sense there that the Phoenicians are,
赤道线，很明显这个故事其实是真的。希罗多德承认，在薛西斯的舰队中，腓尼基人是最好的水手。现在，希腊人对腓尼基人的态度在波斯战争后变得强硬起来，因为很明显，腓尼基人在试图击败希腊人的过程中扮演了关键角色，而这些人在萨拉米斯战役中被击败了。所以希腊人怀恨在心，对吧？他们不会轻易放过这件事。是的，他们确实如此。伯罗奔尼撒战争的伟大历史学家修昔底德将腓尼基人描述为野蛮人。他说，实际上，最初定居西西里岛的是腓尼基人，但后来他们被希腊殖民者赶走了。他认为这绝对是了不起的。我认为这其中有一种感觉，即腓尼基人，
unlike the Persians, are kind of sinister doppelgangers of the Greeks, that they're simultaneously alien and similar, and that's what makes them unsettling. And I think you get the same thing actually in the Bible, that the biblical writers are alarmed by, let's call them the Phoenicians, because they are so recognizable. They are so similar. And that's why the hostility develops. Because they're big rivals, right? I mean, they're commercial rivals, cultural rivals. Yes. But because they're so similar, that in a way accentuates the hostility. So there's no question that the Phoenicians are the rivals of the Greeks in this early period, going from Homer up to, I suppose, the time of the Persian Wars. And then Carthage inherits that mantle, and Carthage fights against the Greeks in Sicily, and then, of course,
与波斯人不同，他们是希腊人某种阴险的替身，他们既是外来者又与希腊人相似，这正是让他们感到不安的原因。我认为你在《圣经》中也发现了同样的情况，圣经作者们对腓尼基人感到惊恐，因为他们太容易辨认了。他们太相似了。这就是敌意产生的原因。因为他们是巨大的竞争对手，对吧？我的意思是，他们是商业竞争对手，文化竞争对手。是的。但正因为他们太相似了，这在某种程度上加剧了敌意。所以毫无疑问，腓尼基人是这一早期时期希腊人的竞争对手，从荷马时代一直到我想是波斯战争时期。然后迦太基继承了这一衣钵，迦太基在西西里岛与希腊人作战，然后当然，
against Rome. And the Romans inherit the suspicion of the Phoenicians and particularly the Carthaginians. So they have this phrase, punica fides, so punic faith. Punic derives from the Latin word for Phoenician. And it's the Greeks and the Romans who major in this story about child sacrifice. So there are over 30 Greek and Roman writers who refer to it. 30? Yeah. And so Flaubert, I mean, he gets the idea for child sacrifice from the Greek writers and he gets the idea specifically that they are being sacrificed to Moloch from the Bible
对抗罗马。罗马人继承了对腓尼基人，特别是迦太基人的怀疑。所以他们有这样一个短语，punica fides，即“布匿人的诚信”。Punic源自拉丁语中腓尼基人的意思。正是希腊人和罗马人主要讲述了这个关于儿童献祭的故事。所以有超过30位希腊和罗马作家提到了它。30位？是的。所以福楼拜，我的意思是，他从希腊作家那里得到了儿童献祭的想法，并且他特别从《圣经》中得到了他们被献祭给摩洛克的想法，
and he blends it to create that extraordinary passage that we opened the show with. So I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we should see, well, what are we to make of all this? Okay. So there's a lot going on there, Tom. There's a lot of different sources, lots of different traces. And the second half, why don't we try to pull it all together and say, who were the Phoenicians and what was their influence on Carthage and what's Carthage all about? So come back after the break and we'll find out. Very exciting. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
他将这些融合在一起，创造了我们在节目开头提到的那段非凡的段落。所以我认为我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们应该看看，好吧，我们该如何看待这一切？好的。那里有很多内容，汤姆。有很多不同的来源，很多不同的痕迹。在下半场，我们为什么不试着把这一切整合起来，说说腓尼基人是谁，他们对迦太基有什么影响，以及迦太基到底是怎么回事？所以休息后回来，我们会找到答案。非常令人兴奋。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about Carthage, the great rival of ancient Rome. We started with Gustav Flaubert talking about child sacrifice and the kind of lurid, blood-soaked reputation of Carthage.
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。我们正在谈论迦太基，古罗马的伟大对手。我们从古斯塔夫·福楼拜谈论儿童献祭以及迦太基那种耸人听闻、血腥的名声开始。
And Tom, in the first half, you traced Carthage's origins back to Lebanon, to the city of Tyre, and to these people called the Phoenicians. Now, the Phoenicians are one of the great historical mysteries, aren't they? So my question to you very simply is, who are they? Well, I'm not sure they've traditionally been a great mystery. I think most people have assumed that a people called the Phoenicians existed and that that's a fairly unproblematic conceptualization. However, recently, skepticism about the existence of a people called the Phoenicians has become kind of very academically fashionable. And so the debate is typified by two books that have come out within, what, the past six or seven years. So the first is a book
汤姆，在上半场，你追溯了迦太基的起源，回到了黎巴嫩，回到了泰尔城，以及这些被称为腓尼基人的人。现在，腓尼基人是伟大的历史谜团之一，不是吗？所以我很简单地问你，他们是谁？嗯，我不确定他们传统上是否一直是一个巨大的谜团。我认为大多数人都认为存在一个被称为腓尼基人的民族，这是一个相当没有问题的概念化。然而，最近，对是否存在一个被称为腓尼基人的民族的怀疑在学术界变得非常流行。因此，这场辩论以过去六七年内出版的两本书为代表。所以第一本是
called In Search of the Phoenicians by a brilliant ancient historian called Josephine Quinn at Oxford. Yes, I know that book. And she goes in search of the Phoenicians and, spoiler alert, she doesn't find them. She basically says that it's completely wrong to think of there having been a people called the Phoenicians, that this is something that the Greeks have projected onto them, that the people of Tyre thought of themselves as Tyrians, that the people of Sidon thought of themselves as Sidonians. They did not have a collective identity. And essentially, the evidence that she adduces for that is that the great empires of the age in the Near East, they never treat what we might call Phoenicia as a single region,
一本名为《寻找腓尼基人》的书，作者是牛津大学一位杰出的古代历史学家约瑟芬·奎因。是的，我知道那本书。她去寻找腓尼基人，剧透一下，她没有找到他们。她基本上说，认为存在一个被称为腓尼基人的民族是完全错误的，这是希腊人投射在他们身上的东西，泰尔人认为自己是泰尔人，西顿人认为自己是西顿人。他们没有集体认同感。本质上，她为此引用的证据是，近东那个时代的伟大帝国，他们从不把我们可能称之为腓尼基的地区视为一个单一的地区，
as a single province. She says, we have no good evidence for the ancient people that we call Phoenicians identifying themselves as a single people or acting as a stable collective. And she argues, fascinatingly, that the identification of the Phoenicians as a single people reflected cultural assumptions of the 19th and 20th century, the way in which people in Europe were identifying themselves with their primordial ancestors, and that particularly Christians in Lebanon wanted to do the same because it would distinguish them from kind of Muslim Arab identity. Yeah. I mean, it's only the Greeks and the Romans who refer to them as Phoenicians. So the question then is, well, okay, the people of Tyre and Sidon didn't refer to themselves as Phoenicians,
作为一个单一的省份。她说，我们没有充分的证据表明我们称之为腓尼基人的古代民族将自己视为一个单一的民族或作为一个稳定的集体行动。她引人入胜地辩称，将腓尼基人识别为一个单一民族反映了19世纪和20世纪的文化假设，即欧洲人将自己与原始祖先联系起来的方式，特别是黎巴嫩的基督徒想要这样做，因为这会将他们与某种穆斯林阿拉伯身份区分开来。是的。我的意思是，只有希腊人和罗马人才称他们为腓尼基人。所以问题在于，好吧，泰尔和西顿的人民并没有称自己为腓尼基人，
but did they have a sense of themselves as belonging to a kind of collective in the way that the Athenians and Spartans, even as they were fighting with each other, would have recognized themselves as Greek? And there are absolutely academics who still stick up for that tradition. So an equally brilliant book by a scholar called Carolina Lopez-Riez, which came out in 2021, so only three years ago, Phoenicians and the Making of the Mediterranean. I mean, she is clearly nailing her colors to the mast with that title. She absolutely does think that the Phoenicians existed. She says flat out, a Greek or Roman could recognize a Phoenician by specific traits. Okay. Such as? Well, so the gods, the rituals, the temples, the language, the clothes they wore. Roman comedians are always making fun of it. The kind of specializations, the maritime stuff, the trade,
但他们是否有一种属于某种集体的感觉，就像雅典人和斯巴达人，即使在他们互相争斗时，也会认出自己是希腊人？绝对有学者仍然坚持这一传统。所以一位名叫卡罗琳娜·洛佩兹-里兹的学者在2021年，也就是仅仅三年前，出版了一本同样出色的书，《腓尼基人与地中海的塑造》。我的意思是，她显然通过那个标题表明了自己的立场。她绝对认为腓尼基人是存在的。她直截了当地说，希腊人或罗马人可以通过特定的特征认出腓尼基人。好的。比如？嗯，神灵、仪式、寺庙、语言、他们穿的衣服。罗马喜剧演员总是拿这个开玩笑。那种专业化，航海方面的东西，贸易，
all that kind of thing. And so she says the only real problem is that we do not know for sure how our subjects refer to their collective cities and networks, but this is not enough to deny a group identity. For what it's worth, I'm not in any way a specialist in this, but I would side with the idea that there was a kind of inchoate sense among the Tyrians and the Sidonians that they did have a kind of shared cultural identity. Right. But they wouldn't have called themselves the Phoenicians. No. So Carolina Lopez Rios argues that they did call themselves Canaanites, which has kind of been the traditional view. And this is how the biblical writers frame them. So they do frame the people of Tyre as worshippers of Canaanite gods. So in the first book of Chronicles,
所有这类事情。所以她说唯一真正的问题是我们不确定我们的研究对象如何称呼他们的集体城市和网络，但这不足以否认群体认同。无论如何，我绝不是这方面的专家，但我会倾向于认为泰尔人和西顿人之间确实有一种模糊的感觉，即他们确实有一种共享的文化认同。对。但他们不会称自己为腓尼基人。不。所以卡罗琳娜·洛佩兹·里奥斯辩称他们确实称自己为迦南人，这在某种程度上一直是传统的观点。这就是圣经作者描述他们的方式。所以他们确实将泰尔人描述为迦南神灵的崇拜者。所以在《历代志》第一卷中，
a guy called Canaan is the father of Sidon. So Canaan gives his name to the land and he's the father of Sidon who then goes on to found the city. So I think that it's not just the Greeks who are seeing the people of Tyre and Sidon as distinctive. I think the Israelites are doing that as well because Sidon and Tyre are both seen as providing good things, cedar and craftsmen and things like that, and of dangerous things. So in one of the biblical accounts of the life of Jezebel, she's described as being a princess of Sidon, not of Tyre. So you have there a sense that she's interchangeable. It's like Wolverhampton and Birmingham, Tom.
一个叫迦南的人是西顿的父亲。所以迦南给了这片土地他的名字，他是西顿的父亲，西顿后来建立了这座城市。所以我认为不仅仅是希腊人将泰尔和西顿的人民视为独特的。我认为以色列人也是这样做的，因为西顿和泰尔都被视为提供了好东西，雪松和工匠之类的东西，以及危险的东西。所以在关于耶洗别生平的圣经记载之一中，她被描述为西顿的公主，而不是泰尔的。所以你在这里有一种感觉，她是可互换的。这就像伍尔弗汉普顿和伯明翰，汤姆。
Yes. People from outside, foolishly, can't tell the enormous difference between those two places. Actually, I think the obvious comparison is with the Greeks. There aren't actually that many passages where Greeks talk about there being a Hellenic culture. And we don't really have any, let's call it Phoenician literature. So even Josephine Quinn, although she denies the existence of Phoenicians, she's always using Phoenicians in inverted commas. So I think even that is betraying the fact that there is a kind of common culture there. So whether you want to call them Phoenicians or Phoenicians in inverted commas, I think there probably is. So I think that
是的。外面的人愚蠢地无法分辨这两个地方之间的巨大差异。实际上，我认为明显的比较是与希腊人。实际上并没有多少段落提到希腊人谈论存在一种希腊文化。而且我们并没有真正拥有任何我们可以称之为腓尼基文学的东西。所以即使是约瑟芬·奎因，尽管她否认腓尼基人的存在，她也总是把腓尼基人放在引号里。所以我认为即使是这一点也暴露了一个事实，即那里存在一种共同文化。所以无论你想称他们为腓尼基人还是引号里的腓尼基人，我想可能确实存在。所以我认为
the sense that you get in both the Bible and in Greek accounts, that the Phoenicians are formidable sailors and that they are spectacularly wealthy. I think that these probably would have been recognized by the Phoenicians themselves as giving them a kind of common identity. But it is sharpened in the Greek case because the Greeks, in a sense, they are direct rivals. What we were saying before the break, that the Greeks recognize themselves in the Phoenicians. And that's why the rivalry between them, I think, is so kind of intense, because the Greeks know that they are following in the Phoenician way. It's the Phoenicians who have given them the alphabet, which has enabled writing to flourish,
你在《圣经》和希腊记载中得到的那种感觉，即腓尼基人是强大的水手，而且他们极其富有。我认为这些可能已经被腓尼基人自己认可，赋予了他们一种共同的身份。但在希腊人的情况下，这种感觉被强化了，因为希腊人在某种意义上是直接的竞争对手。我们在休息前所说的，希腊人在腓尼基人身上认出了自己。这就是为什么我认为他们之间的竞争如此激烈，因为希腊人知道他们正在追随腓尼基人的方式。是腓尼基人给了他们字母表，这使得写作得以繁荣，
which in turn facilitates trade. But when the Greeks start spreading westwards to set up their own trade network, they find that the Phoenicians have got there before them, that the Phoenicians have occupied all the best spots. Because it's the Phoenicians who basically establish the Mediterranean as a kind of common sea that enable the silver and the iron ore of Spain and Italy to be brought to the Near East, and for Near Eastern fashions to be taken to Italy and to Sardinia and Spain. And when are we talking about here, Tom? I mean, 500 BC, further back, 1000 BC? Further back, say 900, 800, 700. Right. So well before the golden age of Greece. Yes, absolutely. And the Phoenicians have been able to do this because as they've been doing
这反过来促进了贸易。但当希腊人开始向西扩张以建立自己的贸易网络时，他们发现腓尼基人已经先于他们到达了那里，腓尼基人已经占据了所有最好的位置。因为正是腓尼基人基本上将地中海建立为一种共同的海域，使得西班牙和意大利的白银和铁矿石能够被带到近东，并将近东的时尚带到意大利、撒丁岛和西班牙。我们在这里谈论的是什么时候，汤姆？我的意思是，公元前500年，更早，公元前1000年？更早，比如公元前900年、800年、700年。对。所以远在希腊黄金时代之前。是的，绝对。腓尼基人之所以能够做到这一点，是因为正如他们所做的那样
since the third century millennium, they are at the cutting edge of maritime innovation. So they are building faster ships. They are coating the hulls with bitumen. So they're the first to do that to ensure that the water doesn't seep through. And their ships are so streamlined that basically they can travel up to 30 miles a day. That's incredibly quick. And also they can travel at night because they are the people who have developed the use of the pole star so they can use that and the greeks themselves call the pole star the phoenice so they are branding the pole star as phoenician yeah and it's this that has enabled the phoenicians to plant colonies right the way across Southern Africa, including Carthage, supposedly in 814 BC,
自公元前三千年以来，他们处于海上创新的最前沿。所以他们正在建造更快的船只。他们用沥青涂抹船体。所以他们是第一个这样做的人，以确保水不会渗入。而且他们的船只非常流线型，基本上他们每天可以航行多达30英里。这非常快。而且他们可以在夜间航行，因为他们是开发利用北极星的人，所以他们可以使用它，希腊人自己称北极星为“腓尼基星”，所以他们将北极星标记为腓尼基的。是的，正是这一点使腓尼基人能够在整个南非建立殖民地，包括据称在公元前814年建立的迦太基，
but going onwards, Sardinia, Sicily, Southern Spain, and out into the Atlantic. So we mentioned Gardez. And there are some stories, aren't there, Tom? There are sort of exaggerated myths and stuff that they went as far as Cornwall or indeed North America, which I imagine people think now is obviously total tosh. Right. Okay. So the Phoenicians are always looking for raw materials. They're looking for gold, for silver, for copper, for iron, and of course for tin. And to get this, they are going beyond the Pillars of Hercules. They are definitely planting colonies in Atlantic Iberia and Atlantic North Africa. So Portugal or what's now Morocco, basically.
但继续前进，撒丁岛、西西里岛、西班牙南部，并进入大西洋。所以我们提到了加的斯。汤姆，有一些故事，不是吗？有一些夸张的神话之类的，说他们远至康沃尔甚至北美，我想人们现在认为这显然是完全的胡说八道。对。好的。所以腓尼基人总是在寻找原材料。他们在寻找黄金、白银、铜、铁，当然还有锡。为了得到这些，他们正在越过赫拉克勒斯之柱。他们绝对是在大西洋伊比利亚和大西洋北非建立殖民地。所以基本上是葡萄牙或现在的摩洛哥。
Yeah. Whether they go as far as Cornwall, I mean, this is a tradition that's obviously very popular with the Cornish. There's no archaeological evidence for it. There's no explicit written evidence for it. But there is, I mean, this kind of classic ancient history, there is a poem that is written in late antiquity that is drawing on a fifth century poem. Well, a thousand years later. Yes. Okay. Well, sorry, Tom, I'd need a bit more than that.
是的。他们是否远至康沃尔，我的意思是，这是一个显然在康沃尔人中非常流行的传统。没有考古证据支持它。没有明确的书面证据支持它。但是，我的意思是，这种经典的古代历史，有一首写于古代晚期的诗，它借鉴了一首五世纪的诗。嗯，一千年后。是的。好的。好吧，抱歉，汤姆，我需要比这更多的东西。
I know you do. And this mentions a guy called Himilco who sails out into the Atlantic and he brings tin back from a place called the Cassiterides, which might be Cornwall, but equally, you know, it could be Northern Iberia or whatever. I mean, could be. But also we're told in this poem that Himilco had sailed out into the Atlantic ocean and had found there that the sea was covered with thick seaweed. And so it has been posited that perhaps this was the Sagaso Sea. Of course, people have wanted to believe that they might have sailed all the way to America. And there've been various faked lumps of stone with Phoenician
我知道你需要。这提到了一个叫希米尔科的人，他航行到大西洋，从一个叫卡西特里德斯的地方带回了锡，那可能是康沃尔，但同样，你知道，它可能是伊比利亚北部或其他什么地方。我的意思是，可能是。但我们也在这首诗中被告知，希米尔科曾航行到大西洋，发现那里的海面覆盖着厚厚的海藻。因此，有人提出这可能是马尾藻海。当然，人们一直希望相信他们可能一直航行到美洲。并且有各种伪造的刻有腓尼基文字的石块，
writing inscribed in it, but these are all fakes. There's no hard evidence at all. Tom, you've lost all our listeners in the Lebanese American community with this skepticism. Yeah, well, I'm sorry. But there is also evidence from a Greek text called the Periplus, so the sailing round, that a guy called Hanno might have sailed very, very far south down the coast of Africa, sourcing ivory, sourcing those apes perhaps that were referenced in the Bible. And we know that he sees creatures that almost certainly were chimpanzees. So there's definitely a sense, I think, that the Phoenicians are really, really formidable sailors. And Tom, let's get to Carthage. So they're going around establishing these colonies,
但这些都是赝品。根本没有确凿的证据。汤姆，你用这种怀疑态度失去了黎巴嫩裔美国社区的所有听众。是的，好吧，我很抱歉。但也有来自一部名为《航海记》的希腊文本的证据，即一个叫汉诺的人可能沿着非洲海岸航行得非常非常远，寻找象牙，寻找那些可能在《圣经》中提到的猿猴。我们知道他看到了几乎肯定是黑猩猩的生物。所以我认为绝对有一种感觉，即腓尼基人确实是非常强大的水手。汤姆，让我们谈谈迦太基。所以他们四处建立这些殖民地，
probably not in Cornwall, but at least on the shores of the Mediterranean. And obviously the most famous, the one that we began with, is the great city of Carthage. So the traditional date for that is 814 BC. Is that plausible? I think it's highly plausible. I mean, it's a lot more plausible than the date that Virgil gives it, which is of course around the time of the Trojan War. That is not when Carthage is founded, but yes, so probably mid to late 9th century BC, around when thethage is founded, but yes. So probably mid to late ninth century BC, around when the traditional date is. I mean, it seems entirely plausible. And it's one of a number of colonies that are being planted by the Tyrians at this time. So there's also Utica, which is where Cato the Younger in due course will commit suicide. But that was originally called the Old City and
可能不是在康沃尔，但至少在地中海沿岸。显然最著名的一个，我们开始时提到的那个，是伟大的迦太基城。那么传统的日期是公元前814年。这合理吗？我认为这非常合理。我的意思是，它比维吉尔给出的日期要合理得多，那当然是在特洛伊战争时期。那不是迦太基建立的时间，但是的，所以可能是公元前9世纪中后期，大约在传统日期的时候。我的意思是，这看起来完全合理。它是泰尔人在此时建立的众多殖民地之一。所以还有乌提卡，小加图最终将在那里自杀。但那最初被称为“旧城”，而
Carthage is the New City. That's what it means. So, you know, you have a sense there that Carthage is perhaps not even the oldest colony being planted by the Tyrians. But as I say, by around 700 BC, you have Phoenician cities, Phoenician trading posts everywhere from the Atlantic to the Levant. And as I said, nothing like it has been seen in the Mediterranean before. So the Phoenicians or Phoenicians in inverted commas, I mean, these are really, really significant players in the development of trade and in the development of the Mediterranean,
迦太基是“新城”。这就是它的意思。所以，你知道，你有一种感觉，迦太基甚至可能不是泰尔人建立的最古老的殖民地。但正如我所说，到公元前700年左右，你到处都有腓尼基城市、腓尼基贸易站，从大西洋到黎凡特。正如我所说，在地中海之前从未见过这样的事情。所以腓尼基人或引号里的腓尼基人，我的意思是，这些在贸易的发展和地中海的发展中确实是非常非常重要的参与者，
the sense of the Mediterranean as a kind of single C. And evidence for the success of the Phoenicians in kind of cornering Mediterranean trade, I think is found in their very name. So this word phoenix, which the Greeks say comes from this Lebanese king called Phoenix, actually it means perhaps palm tree. So in the late fifth century, Carthage starts minting coins with a palm tree on it as a way of kind of advertising herself to the Greek world that she has a Phoenician identity. But it's likelier that it comes from the Greek word for reddish-purple.
将地中海视为一种单一海域的感觉。我认为腓尼基人在垄断地中海贸易方面的成功证据可以在他们的名字中找到。所以这个词“phoenix”，希腊人说它来自这个叫Phoenix的黎巴嫩国王，实际上它可能意味着棕榈树。所以在五世纪末，迦太基开始铸造带有棕榈树的硬币，作为一种向希腊世界宣传她拥有腓尼基身份的方式。但它更有可能来自希腊语中“红紫色”的意思。
The colour of purple, let's call it purple, comes from probably the most famous of all the Phoenician luxury products, which is a dye, which is made from mucus secreted by a distinctive predatory mollusk called the murex. And these mollusks are found in the Eastern Mediterranean. They're also found on the Atlantic coast of Morocco. And the mucus is secreted, I gather, specifically from the hypobranchial glands. And you can either do it by kind of tickling the mollusks and secreting the mucus that way, or you can just crush their skulls and pull by kind of tickling the mollusks and secreting the mucus that way, or you can just crush their skulls and pull the flesh out. And when you've pulled the flesh out,
紫色的颜色，让我们称之为紫色，可能来自所有腓尼基奢侈品中最著名的一种，这是一种染料，它是由一种独特的掠食性软体动物（称为骨螺）分泌的粘液制成的。这些软体动物在地中海东部被发现。它们也在摩洛哥的大西洋沿岸被发现。我了解到，粘液是专门从鳃下腺分泌的。你可以通过挠软体动物并分泌粘液来做到这一点，或者你可以直接压碎它们的头骨并取出肉。当你取出肉后，
you leave it to dry in the sun, and then you add salt water, depending on how rich you want the color of the dye to be. Of course, I mean, it absolutely stinks. So this is why the dye factories are always on the edge of towns. So in Sidon, they found one pile of shells that's over 130 meters high. So a lot of mollusks are being killed in the cause of making this dye. And it's a very specialized process. So even to this day, it's not really fully understood. And this is the origin of Tyrian purple, which is an expression we still use. Yes, it is. And the association of purple with spectacular wealth is evident in the fact that famously it becomes the color that is associated with Roman emperors. So you can see why naming
你把它放在阳光下晾干，然后加入盐水，这取决于你想要染料的颜色有多浓。当然，我的意思是，它绝对臭气熏天。这就是为什么染料工厂总是在城镇边缘的原因。所以在西顿，他们发现了一堆超过130米高的贝壳。所以为了制造这种染料，大量的软体动物被杀死了。这是一个非常专业的过程。所以即使在今天，它也没有被完全理解。这就是泰尔紫的起源，这是一个我们仍然使用的表达。是的，它是。紫色与巨大财富的联系在这样一个事实中显而易见，即它著名地成为了与罗马皇帝相关的颜色。所以你可以看出为什么以这种奢侈品命名
the Phoenicians after this luxury product, in a way, it's a kind of a grudging acknowledgement of just how completely they've cornered high-end trade. So that's one story that's told about the Phoenicians by the Greeks. The other is this legend about Cadmus introducing the alphabet to Greece, which you asked about. And the consensus of scholars is that Herodotus is right. Hooray. Ah, brilliant. Well done, Herodotus. Yet again, Herodotus gets it right. So the Phoenicians absolutely are the first to develop an alphabet in the sense of a kind of a standardized set of letters representing a range of sounds. And I'm absolutely not a linguist, and I know that linguists are famous for the tolerance
腓尼基人，在某种程度上，这是一种不情愿的承认，承认他们已经完全垄断了高端贸易。所以这是希腊人讲述的关于腓尼基人的一个故事。另一个是关于卡德摩斯将字母表引入希腊的传说，你问过这个问题。学者的共识是希罗多德是对的。万岁。啊，太棒了。干得好，希罗多德。希罗多德又一次说对了。所以腓尼基人绝对是第一个开发出字母表的人，即一套代表一系列声音的标准化字母。我绝对不是语言学家，我知道语言学家以他们听非语言学家描述不同书写风格和脚本时的宽容而闻名。但基本上，腓尼基字母表之所以如此重要，是因为它与之前的东西形成了对比，即使用符号来代表音节或特定单词的脚本。显然，出于这个原因，学习起来要困难得多。所以腓尼基字母表有22个字母。我的意思是，这要容易学习得多。它源自埃及象形文字。原型已经被发现，20世纪初在西奈半岛发现了一些铭文，但腓尼基字母表是第一个字母表，在我们今天使用拉丁字母表的人看来，
with which they listen to non-linguists describing different styles of writing and script. But basically, the reason why the Phoenician alphabet is so significant is that it's kind of in contrast to what had gone before, which is scripts that use symbols to represent either syllables or specific words. And obviously, it's much harder for that reason to learn. So the Phoenician alphabet has 22 letters. I mean, that is much easier to learn. And it's derived from Egyptian hieroglyphs. The prototype has been discovered, some inscriptions were found in the early 20th century in Sinai, but it's the Phoenician alphabet that is the first alphabet in the sense that we who use the Latin alphabet today would recognize
它。它不是象形文字，所以它是一个字母表而不是象形文字。是的，完全正确。符号代表字母而不是事物，可以这么说。是的，完全正确。而且，正如希罗多德所说，它在某种程度上支撑了希腊字母表。没有腓尼基人的例子，希腊字母表是不可能的。希腊字母表反过来影响了我们使用的拉丁字母表。是的，当然。西里尔字母，你知道，西方各种各样的字母表，但它也影响了东方的字母表。所以腓尼基字母表影响了阿拉米语脚本，该脚本被波斯人采用供他们使用。从长远来看，
it. It's not hieroglyphs, so it's an alphabet rather than a hieroglyphic. Yeah, exactly. The symbols stand for letters rather than for things, as it were. Yes, exactly. And, you know, as Herodotus says, it kind of underpins the Greek alphabet. The Greek alphabet would be impossible without the Phoenician example. The Greek alphabet, in turn, influences the Latin alphabet that we use. Yes, of course. The Cyrillic, you know, all kinds of alphabets in the West, but it also influences alphabets in the East. So the Phoenician alphabet influences the Aramaic script, which is adopted by the Persians for their use. And in the
它影响了希伯来语和阿拉伯语。所以腓尼基脚本的影响力令人难以置信。虽然最初它用于贸易，但著名的是，它也开始用于文学。我们没有任何腓尼基文学，但当然我们确实有希腊语写成的第一部伟大史诗，荷马的史诗，如果没有腓尼基人，那是不可想象的。所以我们没有任何东西，字面上没有任何腓尼基人写的东西。那是真的吗？我们有铭文。我们有那种东西。你喜欢铭文。我对铭文的容忍度比你低一点。好吧，是的。正如我们所说，Byblos这个词给了我们希腊语中“书”的意思。
long run, it influences both Hebrew and Arabic. So the Phoenician script is unbelievably influential. And although initially it's used for trade, famously, it also comes to be used for literature. We don't have any Phoenician literature, but of course we do have the first great epics written in Greek, those of Homer, which would be unthinkable without the Phoenicians. So we have nothing, literally nothing written by the Phoenicians. Is that right? We have inscriptions. We have that kind of stuff. You love an inscription. I'm a little bit less tolerant of inscriptions than you are. Well, yeah. And as we said, the word byblos gives us the Greek word for book.
所以我们知道他们有，我的意思是，纸莎草纸之类的东西。是的，他们绝对有。而且似乎很可能正是通过腓尼基人，近东神话，比如吉尔伽美什之类的东西，进入了希腊。希腊神话显然在很大程度上归功于，比如，美索不达米亚神话。而且似乎正是拥有文字的腓尼基人充当了载体。对。所以这为腓尼基人记了一分。实际上是两分。我们有染料，我们有字母表。
So we know that they had, I mean, papyruses or whatever. Yeah, they absolutely did. And it seems likely that it's via the Phoenicians that Near Eastern myth, so Gilgamesh and that kind of thing, enters Greece. Greek mythology clearly owes a lot to, say, Mesopotamian mythology. And it seems to be the Phoenicians with their writing that kind of serve as the vectors. Right. So that's one chalked up for the Phoenicians. Two, actually. We've got the die and we've got the alphabet.
是的，干得好。但是多米尼克，儿童献祭呢？所以这就是我们开始时提到的。汤姆，我一直在等这一集的这个内容。那么你的感觉是什么？嗯，我对这个一无所知，但我会说我愿意相信他们做了。我认为如果他们做了，这一集会更好。我认为我们想以一个人们会记住的高调结束。我们不想一直做揭穿者，汤姆。对。好吧，你会很高兴，因为我会说直到90年代，可能，学者们的共识是
Yeah, well done. But Dominic, what about the child sacrifice? So this is what we began with. I've been waiting on an episode for this, Tom. So what would be your sense? Well, I know nothing about this, but I would say I'd like to believe they did it. I think it makes a better episode if they did it. I think we want to end on a high on a note that people will remember. We don't want to just be debunkers all the time, Tom. Right. Well, you're going to be pleased because I would say that up until, say, the 90s, probably, the consensus among scholars was that
这一切都是希腊-罗马的宣传。希腊人和罗马人在“他者化”腓尼基人。当然。他们在东方化他们，汤姆。又是令人震惊的场景。但我认为现在共识是迦太基人确实参与了儿童献祭。原因在于，越来越多的圣所被发现，这些圣所似乎恰恰指向了这一点。所以实际上，这些大约在100年前就已经为人所知了。所以这些是由石头标记的露天围场，里面装满了骨灰瓮，其中一些包含牲畜的烧焦遗骸，主要是羊，但其中一些包含小孩的烧焦遗骸。所以不出所料，这些被命名为“托菲特”，取自《圣经》中的那个地方。
it was all Greco-Roman propaganda. The Greeks and the Romans were othering the Phoenicians. Of course. They were orientalizing them, Tom. Again, shocking scenes. But I think now the consensus would be that the Carthaginians did engage in child sacrifice. And the reason for that is that more and more sanctuaries have been found which seem to point to exactly that. So actually, these have been known about for about 100 years now. So these are open air enclosures marked out by stones, full of urns, some of which contain the burned remains of livestock, mostly sheep, but some of which contain the burned remains of small children. And so unsurprisingly, these have been named Tophets after the place in the Bible.
第一个是在一个叫莫奇亚的地方发现的，那是西西里岛外的一个岛屿，非常非常重要的腓尼基城市。然后在1921年，也就是莫奇亚那个发现后的两年，在迦太基本身实际上发现了一个巨大的。所以你看，迦太基并非一切都被摧毁了。我的意思是，它很大。所以它大约有30,000平方米，大约20,000个丧葬骨灰瓮。你知道，这些是在许多许多年里被放在那里的。如果似乎有一个
And the first one was found at a place called Mochia, which was an island off Sicily, very, very significant Phoenician city. And then in 1921, so this was two years after the one in Mochia, an enormous one was actually found in Carthage itself. So you see, not everything in Carthage was destroyed. I mean, it was huge. So it was about 30,000 square meters, about 20,000 funerary urns. You know, these were being put there over the course of many, many years. And if there seems to be a
某种圣经中关于托菲特的联系，托菲特的使用，我们不知道迦太基人称它为什么，但《圣经》提供了一个方便的名字。在这些托菲特中还有许多铭文，明确指出孩子们是作为祭品给出的，腓尼基语中这种祭品的词是“molk”。哦，像摩洛克。多令人兴奋。像摩洛克。所以很可能摩洛克根本不是一个神，而是一种牺牲，一种儿童的祭品。所以我认为福楼拜确实弄错了一点，即孩子们被献祭给的神不是摩洛克，而是另一个神。在迦太基，它是巴力-哈蒙神和他的王后塔尼特。巴力意味着“主”，而哈蒙似乎来自腓尼基语“hamam”。
kind of biblical link in Tophet, the use of Tophet, we don't know what the Carthaginians called it, but the Bible provides a convenient name. There are also lots of inscriptions in these Tophets explicitly stating that the children have been given as an offering and the Phoenician word for this offering is a molk. Oh, like Moloch. How exciting. Like Moloch. And so it's likely that Moloch was not a god at all, but a kind of sacrifice, an offering of a child. So that is something I think that Flaubert does get wrong, that the god that children are being offered to is not Moloch, but another god. And in Carthage, it's a god called Baal-Hamon and his queen called Tanit. And Baal means lord, and Hamon seems to come from the Venetian word hamam.
抱歉，汤姆，那是什么？哈曼？哈曼？哈曼？好的。没有元音。对。似乎来自腓尼基语“hummum”。抱歉，汤姆，那是什么？哈曼？哈曼？哈曼？好的。没有元音。对。这意味着展示我在腓尼基语方面的专业知识。
Sorry, Tom, what was that again? Hamam? Hamam? Hamam? Okay. No vowels. Right. Seems to come from the Venetian word hummum. Sorry, Tom, what was that again? Humm? Humm? Humm? Okay. No vowels. Right. And this means display my expertise in Venetian.
是的，去做吧。我一直在查阅博德利图书馆。这意味着热或炽热，火。所以他是好的。热巴力，这就是他的名字。好吧，不，不是热巴力。熔炉之主。哦，对。
Yeah, go for it. I've been consulting the Bodleian. This means hot or a blaze, a fire. So he's good. Hot Baal, that's his name. Well, no, not Hot Baal. Lord of the Furnace. Oh, right.
我更喜欢热巴力。我认为比起称自己为熔炉之主，你会用热巴力获得更多的点击量。熔炉之主。哦，对。我更喜欢热巴力。我认为比起称自己为熔炉之主，你会用热巴力获得更多的点击量。熔炉之主相当令人不寒而栗。还有塔尼特。塔尼特在《萨朗波》里。是的。是的，她是。她不是塔尼特的祭司吗？
I like Hot Baal better. I think you'll get more clicks with Hot Baal than calling yourself Lord of the Furnace. Lord of the Furnace. Oh, right. I like Hotbar better. I think you'll get more clicks with Hotbar than calling yourself Lord of the Furnace. Lord of the Furnace is pretty chilling. And Tanit. Tanit is in Salonbo. Yeah. Yeah, she is. Isn't she a priestess of Tanit?
月亮女神？类似的东西。是的。是的，塔尼特和巴力-哈蒙同样是迦太基的两位伟大神灵。约瑟芬·奎因在她的书《寻找腓尼基人》中，有一章关于托菲特的精彩而迷人的内容，她指出，尽管西方有许多腓尼基定居点确实实行这种儿童献祭，但也有许多没有实行。所以这不是一个标记，用她的话说，引号里的
The goddess of the moon? Something like that. Yes. Yeah. Tanit and Balhamon are equally the two great gods of Carthage. And Josephine Quinn, in her book, In Search of the Phoenicians, has a brilliantly fascinating chapter on the Tophets in which she points out that although there are lots of Phoenician settlements across the West that do practice this child sacrifice, there are also lots that don't. So it's not something that is a marker of inverted commas, as she would put it,
腓尼基身份。而且它在腓尼基本身最迟在7世纪就已经绝迹了，所以她认为这种崇拜的相对稀缺意味着托菲特的使用者一定形成了一个有自我意识的群体，这是一种罕见且高度独特的仪式选择，她的论点是迦太基实际上不是泰尔的官方殖民地，而是可能由逃避主流对他们对儿童献祭的热情的不赞成的定居者建立的。哦，天哪，汤姆。所以它确实是泰尔的大英帝国的美国。对。所以她明确了这一点。她说，就像清教徒向新世界的出走，
Phoenician identity. And it's definitely died out in phoenicia itself by at the latest the 7th century and so she argues the relative scarcity of this cult means that the users of the tophets must have formed a self-conscious group this was a rare and highly distinctive ritual choice and her thesis is that carthage was actually not an official colony of tyre but may have been founded by settlers who were fleeing mainstream disapproval of their enthusiasm for child sacrifice. Oh my God, Tom. So it really is the United States to Tyre's Great Britain. Right. So she makes this explicit. She says, like the exodus of the Puritans to the new world,
托菲特圈的形成可能是对西方新机遇和东方新宗教限制的反应。母国的一个阴险而怪异的分支。哇。这是一个了不起的理论，不是吗？是的，我喜欢它。它相当迷人。她还指出，狄多（Dido）的故事，它涉及背叛、欺骗和逃亡，这不是一个带着母城祝福被派出的殖民者的故事，也许这是宗教流亡者这一现实的扭曲回声。所以汤姆，实际上我们在这一集中绕了一圈，因为我们从福楼拜的书《萨朗波》中那个极其耸人听闻和暴力的场景开始，这在1860年代
the formation of the circle of the Tophet could have been a reaction both to new opportunities in the West and new religious restrictions in the East. A sinister and freakish offshoot of the motherland. Wow. It's an amazing theory, isn't it? Yeah, I love it. It's kind of fascinating. And she points out also that the story of Dido, that it involves betrayal and deception and flight, that it's not a story of colonists being sent out with the blessing of the mother city. And that perhaps this is a distorted echo of the reality that it was kind of religious exiles. So Tom, actually we've come full circle in the episode because we started with that incredibly lurid and violent scene from Flaubert's book Salombo, which has
绝对让人们感到震惊，这是可以理解的。实际上，我们回到了这样一个想法，即尽管有关于东方化和他者化的一切，迦太基很可能是在地中海沿岸由某种儿童献祭崇拜建立的，当然，它会演变成罗马的伟大对手。是的。而且可能不仅仅是希腊人和罗马人带着恐惧看着这一点，许多引号里的腓尼基人也会这样做。是的。而且可能不仅仅是希腊人和罗马人带着恐惧看着这一点，许多引号里的腓尼基人也会这样做。是的。来自老家的人。天哪。但这只是强调了尝试不通过希腊人、罗马人或非儿童献祭的腓尼基人的眼睛，而是通过
absolutely scandalized people in the 1860s, understandably. And actually, we've come back to the idea that for all the stuff about orientalizing and othering, quite possibly Carthage was set up by a kind of child sacrifice cult on the shores of the Mediterranean and, of course, would evolve into the great rival to Rome. Yeah. And that possibly it's not just the Greeks and the Romans who are looking at this with horror, that many of, inverted comma, Phoenicians would have done as well. Yeah. And that possibly it's not just the Greeks and the Romans who are looking at this with horror, that many of inverted comma Phoenicians would have done as well. Yeah. People from the old country. Crikey. But that just emphasizes the importance of trying to see the world not through Greek or Roman or non-child-sacrificing Phoenician eyes, but through
迦太基人自己的眼睛来看待世界的重要性。也许，我们下次能做到吗？我们能进入迦太基人的头脑吗？这就是我们为自己设定的挑战。所以下次我们会回来，我们将看看迦太基本身。我们对迦太基的起源、迦太基的性格、迦太基的历史了解多少？太棒了。好的。
the eyes of the Carthaginians themselves. And maybe, could we do that next time? Can we get into the Carthaginian heads? That is the challenge we have set ourselves. So next time we'll come back and we will look at Carthage itself. What do we know about the origins of Carthage, the character of Carthage, the history of Carthage? Superb. All right.
所以下次我们将谈论迦太基。现在，如果你想成为我们自己阴险崇拜的一部分。死亡崇拜。这是《剩下的就是历史》俱乐部。你现在有点知道流程了。如果你想成为我们自己阴险崇拜的一部分，死亡崇拜，这是《剩下的就是历史》俱乐部。你现在有点知道流程了。Therestishistory.com注册，你将获得关于迦太基和迦太基心态的下一集。然后你将获得关于迦太基与罗马伟大超级大国竞争爆发的后续剧集。我们会立即获得它们以及许多其他好处。当然，如果你已经是我们阴险死亡崇拜的成员，好吧，你可能已经喜欢听广告了，所以在那
So next time we'll be talking about Carthage. Now, if you'd like to be part of our own sinister cult. Death cult. It's the Rest Is History Club. You kind of know the drillage now. If you'd like to be part of our own sinister cult, death cult, it's the Rest Is History Club. You kind of know the drill by now. Therestishistory.com to sign up and you will get the next episode about Carthage and the Carthaginian mindset. And then you will get the next episodes about the outbreak of Carthage's great superpower rivalry with Rome. We'll get them straight away and a host of other benefits. If of course you're already a member of our sinister death cult, well, you'll probably have enjoyed hearing the advert anyway so on that
重磅炸弹上，非常感谢你，汤姆，那太迷人了，我们下次再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
bombshell thank you very much tom that was fascinating and we'll see you all next time goodbye bye-bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
重磅炸弹，非常感谢你，汤姆，这太迷人了，我们下次再见，再见，再见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想收听无广告版本、获取额外剧集并提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击逐字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。